yo what is up everybody it is
prestigious mad luigi here with another
borderlands dp sequel legendary guide
today we're going to be looking at the
striker which is a legendary jacobs
shotgun
its red text reads reads fan deer 13. it
has always has a bonus critical hit
damage mine has 72 percent
and it fires as fast as you can pull the
trigger like many other jacob's weapons
now i have 14 47 times 9 is the damage i
think that can range
i believe that you can have a difference
in number of projectiles so they can be
eight or seven but it's always going to
be a
fairly good damage with a fairly good
amount of bullets being shot out at the
price of
one bullet now what makes this shotgun
special is that you can see the accuracy
is 83.8 and it has a very sma
small reticle for most shotguns that
means you can hit a lot
more precise shots and with the crit
damage that gives you a lot
better opportunity to take advantage of
the crit damage
with the better shots other than most
other shotguns however
and it does have a high extremely high
fire rate because it can you can
shoot it as fast as you want to however
the magazine size is
two and now it does have a fast reload
speed of 2.3
magazine size i think can range from
like two to three
but it is a very small magazine size you
can with nisha there is the skill
to bump every magazine size up by three
that gives you five shots that does make
the gun a lot better
however its neutral state is at a lower
uh
amount of the magazine size which is i'd
say the one downside to this
shotgun otherwise it is a pretty
all-around great shotgun so i'm going to
show you where you get it
and kind of how it kills enemies in this
video so i hope you enjoy all right so
the first thing you're going to want to
do is you're going to want to travel to
crisis scar
and because this shotgun is going to be
farmed from the
boss red belly which is a completely
reformable boss you can go through the
main storyline
and come back here any time to kill him
so you're gonna see you're gonna spawn
here you're just gonna run
all the way up it's a nice run and i'm
gonna show you a little shortcut so that
you can shorten the run every single
time you kill him so you can make the
run a lot faster
now instead of turning left here to go
fight him you're gonna go
pull right and you're gonna travel to
triton flats and travel back so every
time you save and quit after you kill
him if you do not get the gun on your
first drop which
chances are you probably won't but hey
maybe you'll have better luck than me i
farmed them something like 50 times
you're going to travel back to crisis
car and now every time you save and quit
you will spawn right there so i'm going
to show you a route that you can take to
avoid most confrontation you can skip
past basically every single enemy
up until red belly which will make this
a lot faster just kind of follow where i
do my jumps and the big part here is
you're gonna jump on this light post and
jump over so you don't have to wait for
the
door to open normally that door when you
have to kill all the enemies in the area
to get it to open and then you have to
fight more enemies
so i excluded a ton of enemy fights
right there and now you're already at
red and belly
and you can go up to him and just start
fighting him right away
now you're going to want to take out red
belly's health to about two-thirds of
the way
after that just stop shooting him and
let him run to his middle where he
splits up into red and belly is two
separate guys you can throw some
grenades in there like i do
beforehand because you know where he's
gonna be and now this shotgun only has a
chance to drop
from belly so you can kind of just
ignore red red is the guy that flies
around has the helmet belly is the big
fat guy
who has the uh the main gun and will try
and be in the face
so you're gonna want to kill belly and
if he doesn't drop it you can just save
and quit right then
he does drop a lot of skins and pretty
good loot so you might want to be able
to check that out there's
also a chest where i end up killing him
and getting the
uh striker shotgun there's a chest in
that room they can get every time it's
pretty good chest
might want to check it out so if you
don't get it from belly just save and
quit come back
and bingo you can see there i got the
rustler striker
i do not know what the wrestlers prefix
uh does
i do not know the entire list prefix for
this gun but you and you can see and
this is the room that i'm talking about
it has the chest behind me i don't
i don't pick it up on this run or i did
beforehand and
here is me just me using the shotgun the
rest of this video is just going to be
some gameplay of me
killing enemies with the shotgun it
doesn't work too well in red because any
crit hits you get on him
uh have a chance to bullets or to
reflect to you
and hurt you so just be careful if you
want to kill bread
when if when you do get the shotgun now
you're gonna see here
the it does have that longer range
scoping in does improve
the reduce the recoil i should say but
even if i'm down and the guy's
15 feet away a lot of other shotguns
wouldn't be able to do as much damage
quickly because a lot of the bullets
would spread out and you wouldn't get
kills
on them and you can see that the crit
damage does help
since i am aiming for their heads and i
can aim from farther away
the crit damage and the accuracy coupled
together
to be pretty good so that's kind of it
for the guide of how to get it and what
it's like
i think it's a pretty good shotgun i've
consistently used it i do think i have a
better purple shotgun however that just
might be based on my play style and
build i don't build specifically for the
striker shotgun however you can
and it will be an effective weapon so if
you especially if you don't have another
shotgun this is a going to be a great
shotgun for you to use
and i do highly recommend using this in
your build
so that's going to be it for me in the
video i do hope you guys have enjoyed
this video i appreciate you got all the
way to the end
and i will be posting a bunch of other
borderlands the sequel legendary
and content and other content so i hope
you stick around and check out my
channel for more of that stuff
and thank you for watching the video god
bless